Well,
there's a vast number to choose from and
perhaps it's worth emphasizing the
arbitrary nature of the selection
process if once thinking in terms of
billions of past human beings,
it's extraordinary,
uh,
how hard it is to make a selection and
generally the selection has been made
for you,
but previous historians by posterity,
by the contemporaries who built statues
or books about a famous men and women.
And so often one finds oneself writing
about people who are already a great or
evil men or women before you even show
up.
But I find myself recently in,
in the book called the war of the world
writing considerable amount about
Winston Churchill,
Joseph Stalin at all fit Franklin
Roosevelt,
the stars,
heroes and villains of,
of the 20th century.
But part of what I do is to try to,
to write the history of non political
institutions,
like firms to look at the history of,
of capitalism,
the history of business,
and to give equal billing to
entrepreneurs as well as to generals and
politicians.
Because I think the history of modernity
actually requires that balance to be
struck.
And then you get to know slightly less
familiar figures.
The first hero of any book I ever wrote
was a German Jewish banker named Max
Viral called Warburg.
Uh,
who turned into the hero of my doctoral
dissertation rather,
to my own surprise,
simply because as I rummaged around in
archives and Humberg trying to
understand why Germany had imploded
economically in the 1920s,
he kept cropping up and emerged as the
central,
a hero of,
of,
of my first book paper and Darren,
oh.